turned out for a very special edition of
mom tags and we have a special visitor
our in-studio today for this installment
my waters doctor waters excuse me
so let's get started as many of you know
my mom is a liberal democrat and sends
me texts during the show critiquing my
performance yes
text 1 when you are good you are so very
very good and when there is a
performance like last night's I've
become so distraught that you have moved
ever closer to that imaginary line that
cannot be crossed next one I have
delighted in your more measured in
thoughtful language and approach to
issues these last months and I've said
that to you so then I began to ender is
this mean Mondays because this only
happens on Monday yes I am tired of the
Fox and Friends fellow think about how
to make the world a better place and
lastly all I can say is thank God for
one William is really Jesse celebrity
now she gets into the green room and
everyone's like I heard she's in the
green room can I go yeah she's pretty
great I know and most of them are very
complimentary of you Dana and gutfeld
when she says your name correctly yes
she does think you're interesting I
think but what this does is people are
surprised that you are actually born you
came from human beings does this
humanize me barely here's a special one
I think someone is going to like this
one number three as usual Dana provided
wisdom and big thing my mom is your
biggest fan thank you no that's just
about you Dana how about this one you
might remember this from two weeks ago
number one please apologize to your
colleagues and I mean with genuine
remorse
for the horrific judgment you showed in
airing your Santa video be a great
our careful Jessie everyone is
replaceable except Santa showing it
again so I'm very sorry and I think
Kimberly will like this one okay please
don't become a talking head that is
predictable and thin your colleagues
roll their eyes and groan aloud with
their pregame knowledge of what your
position and point is you know we are
our eyes roll with love
[Laughter]